foreign
[Music]
you probably recognize these ice cream
pellets as the ice cream of the future
they're Dippin Dots a summertime staple
but this confectionary treat didn't
start as well ice cream it started as
cow feed
[Music]
Dippin Dots were invented in the 80s not
by an ice cream brand but by a
microbiologist Curtis Jones specialized
in cryogenics in 1987 he was working for
a biotech company in Kentucky trying to
figure out how to make food for farm
animals more efficient
his big breakthrough came when he flash
froze cattle feed 350 degrees below zero
which produced small pellets
serendipitously Curtis loved making ice
cream next thing he knew he was using
liquid nitrogen to freeze ice cream at
extremely low temperatures and ended up
with small beads of it when eaten the
natural heat of the mouth melted the
beads and thus Dippin Dots was born
a year later he formed the company out
of his parents Garage in Illinois but
there was a problem Curtis had nowhere
to sell the product Dippin Dots need to
be stored at such a cold temperature
that it made it impossible for grocery
stores to house the tasty treat so he
got creative and marketed his product to
alternate locations now they're sold at
amusement parks festivals zoos and other
summertime destinations but whether or
not they really are the ice cream of the
future
we'll just have to wait and see
[Music]
the queen Amman is a specialty of
northern France derived from the Baton
words for butter and Cake the ratio for
this pastry is special it's buttery in
fact it's 30 butter and 30 sugar
[Music]
welcome to duardine a city with a
population of around 15 000. this small
coastal town has a few main attractions
including touring the coastlines
visiting the port Museum and seeing the
Chappelle of San Michelle
but that's not why we're here we are
here to meet Terry Luka the man to talk
to when you want a truly authentic Queen
Aman pastry
um
a
Acadian people was a legend goes a baker
ran out of goods in their shop and had
to whip up something quickly because
[Music]
the pastry has only a few simple
ingredients but don't let that fool you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
not to have the last word but obviously
we tried it
Bon Appetit and I think our face says it
all and also this spontaneous remark oh
my God that's so buttery
[Music]
10 out of 10 would recommend
Ed
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
United
[Music]
Airlines
[Music]
[Music]
minus
[Music]
is
[Music]
me
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
loves ice cream even those who say they
don't like ice cream
still love ice cream
we use ice cream as a way to support our
community
[Music]
my name is Michael Mikey Cole and I own
Mikey likes an ice cream
I did not always sell ice cream I was
born in the Lower East Side of New York
City's Village two blocks from the shop
while selling drugs at one point I ended
up getting caught and I'm going to jail
for six months a few years ago my mother
got sick I promised to her that I
wouldn't be locked up anymore and do the
wrong things ice cream was something
that just came into my life at a time
when I didn't really know what I was
kind of doing
[Music]
this is Pop Culture inspired ice cream
we have Jack and Jill A Couple Shuffle
Ice Ice Baby Pink Floyd Mint Condition
southern hospitality and we have smooth
operators
a bunch of famous people have come by
here Futures are fan joaquim Noah is a
fan Hillary Clinton's a fan
we have a lot of other fans out there as
well
I still live two blocks from the store
part of our job is to still be heavily
in the community and so kids come in
here with a a on their report card we
give them a free scoop of ice cream just
to show them that we are the same as
them so I'm just a little older but I'm
still the same child at heart and if you
can find something that you like and
you're passionate about go forth and
just go for it you know don't don't not
go for your dreams go for every last one
that you have
[Music]
at the end of World War II the Soviets
were holding Berlin Under Siege
in order to save millions of people from
starvation the US and allies devised a
plan to airlift in food
one American pilot decided to take it a
step further he delivered candy
my name is Gail Halverson but I've known
as the Berlin candy Barber
I didn't think that the airlifted lasts
very long so I thought I'd better get a
movie of this operation before they send
me home one day while filming the planes
taking off and Landing Gail became aware
that there was some young children
watching him he went over to talk to
them and after a while he realized
dummy don't you know kids like chocolate
and I knew that they had not had
chocolate in the stores in Berlin for
two years and I realized my pocket and I
all I had was two sticks of Wrigley's
double name gum and I broke the two
sticks and a half gave the kids and the
kids would have a stick tore off the
wrapper in the thin strips and passed it
through those without gun to those who
received the wrappers put it up their
nose and smelled a piece of wrapper
inspired by their generosity he decided
that next flight he would drop them
chocolate and candy via Parachute from
the plane they said how do we know what
airplane you're in and so I said when I
come over the Airfield a wiggle the
wings of that big airplane they said oh
great true to his word the next day Gale
began to drop the packages
what started with just two sticks of gum
eventually turned into 23 tons of
chocolate
from then on I was not in the press and
all the kids in Berlin I thought but
Wiggly wings and in case you were
wondering if the Candy Bomber still has
a sweet tooth oh yeah I still eat
chocolate I like dark chocolate
[Music]